THAT NEWS CONFERENCE TO U  IT BL
THEN, LET'RNLITH
MAJOR STORY OF THE DAY, A JUDGEH
SI DONALD TRUMP
TODAY,EJ OF EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE ITH
UMVESTIGATION.
FOOP W TIFY BEFORE A GRAND JURY.
JURYOU T THE LIST
INCLUDES FORMER WHIOUCHIEF OFFF,
FORMER DIRECTO OF NATIONAL
INTELLIGEN. JOHN RATCLIFFE, N
RO AND OTHERS.
OF THESE HAVE ALREADY
LIKE BREY ONCE ANDO MENTS AS CNA
SCHNEIDERL
Y TO
APDECISION. TRUMP'SESTERS ORDERE
DEBES A FEDER
DGE O
EXECUTE PGE ORDERING
STAFF MARK MEADOWSR DE MILLER AE
REMB LEANING AGAINST THE
SOUN LGO TO SAYING INTERTIERSATY
THE CAPITALWAOW
CAPITAL, DIDN'TOO HIS
ON, CASS, BUT I DON'T KNOW. GET.
SEPARATELY CORCORAN, A TOP TMPRE
CLASSIFI DOCUMENTS, PROBE,
SPENDING FOUR HOUR
TESTIFYING BEHINDEDERALND
FRIDAY. TRUMP ALSO FOUGHT I TSTT
L JUDGES RULING CORCORANNFORMATT
CORC M OVENDWRITTENENTING
THEIRONS. FBI
SEIZED MORANIFIED
DOCUMENTS FMA I
AUGU SHOULD GIVE ME
TH'VSEATELY BAVE
MINE. IT'S MINE. FBAGSEIZED MORD
ST, AMONG OTHER JACK SMITH
WHUCDNT'S ATTEMPTS TO GET
LEFT OFFICEOR MATERI IN HIS POSI
AT 2022A
TS HADTE AND THAT
NED. A SOURCE TELLS
CNN PROSECUTORS TO ASK
CORCENTE CALL BETWT TOOK PLACE
THE AS SUBPNAEDORAN SHOWEDXES BA
E ROOM. UTILL HAVTHEILLANCEAPE.Y
PROSECUTORS HAVE MADER THATH T
OR TO ADVANCE A CRIME SPOKE H
CK, ACCUSING T J
DEPARTMENT OF CONTINUOUSLY
STEPPINGRDDESTROY THE LONG ACCEG
HELD BEDRDS O CLITPRIVILEGE A EE
PRIVILEGEINNING HE
S TRIED TO COOPERATERNEY TIM PAN
. HE ALSOESCEMBER,
DIAI ABOUT
UMENTS
YEARHER MAKE
THIS INTO AN ADVERSARIAL FIGHT L
JACK SMITH WILL NOW ET
AN INFLUX OF NEWO WAS
FOEDSTIFY OF
THE GRAND JURY TODAY AND ALSO
FROM THAT ARRAYRUMP, WHO NOW TEE
GRAND JURY ABOSPED
ARY
JAKE. OUR TEAM IS TOLD THAT
TRUMP'S LEGAL TEAM IS EXPECTED
TO APPEAL THIDECISIONLET SS
IN THAT
SOME OF THESE FI HAVE
ALREADY BEEN SUBPOENAED LIKE THE
FORMER NNAY RT O'BRIEN
CUCCINLI FROM HOMELAND
SECUTY, IT'S LIKHAVEGOK M THAT A
LOTOUT HERESO MUCHOUT TH NENIOY
LET'SK ABOUT THERT TELLING THESE
APPEAL THEY CASE TO
MA AXECUTIVE PRIGECASE?KENLY HAO
WIN.Y'
. FIRST
EXECUTE ISIGN TO PROTNMENTA
CONVERSATIONS LEGITIMATELICYGITS
IT'S N
FOREASANCE
WALSURY
SUBPOENA. JUDGESY
TOSE SUBPOENAS VERYO LO ASSTI
OF HIS EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGESECON,
IDHILE A FORMER
IDXECUTIVEE IN VERY NARROWS. S O
TR ALSOT
EXECUTIVEOPENT PENCE FROM BEING
RCTESTIFYDO YOUHITHIS RULING SIT
LLKE YESTERDAY
SAHAP HAD VIRTUALLY NO
CHANCE TO SUC ON THE MIKE
I. THERE'S A SEPARATE
ARGUMENT ON THE PENCE CASE
BECAUSE MIKE PENCT A
EG
IDEA OF SPEECH AE, AS VICE PRESE
QUESTIONS ABOUTHA ROLE AS SEN PE
THERE ANY WAY THAT MEAWST OUT O?
CAN TTH TMEAT ANYMOLY OOUT
P DO HAVE AD AGAINST THEM. THET
TERMOVE AVAILABLE CAN
GE
ORDERIM, MEANING YOUR
TE ISOING T AGAINST YOU. BUTHAVD
THAT
DECISION QUITE FREQUEN BHEY GETY
UNLY TO BE AUTE. YOU W MARK
IS JUST A GAMEUTSOLEWS A I LE PH
AMENDMENT RIGHTST SELF
PROSECUTOR, YOO SAYS. WE'UN
YOURSE AND
THEN WHAO AR
MEADOWS AND WHAT DO D
THE PROSECUTOR? SO THIS IS NOT
ECUTOR
MARK MEADOWS IMMUNITY TOOESN'TTR
NOT. AND IF HEEF, IF C FORCE THE
F MY MOUTH. THEN
SITUATION AND Y THOSE WHO HISTOA
CLINTON
WENTO8S FOR
RESTIFYSOMES DOWN TIT IF DOJAY
SAYS, YAN TALUDGE CAN ABSOLUTELY
THROWING MARK MEADO OR WHOEVER
ITSON UNTIL
TAKEBEHIND THECEU' A PCUUT THE
ALL THESE PELE WHOAVE HAD
E  ONE CONRS
DO TRUMP AROUND JANUARY 6T
AND ARE YOU PREPARINGFIRST OF AO
QUESTIONTH YOU WANT TO CE
SEVERAL DOCUM FOR SUBPOENAS.
I WANTNG
J, 6TH COMMITTEE DID.
HEARD A CASSIDYCH WOU REVIEW EV,
BECAUSEHE WAS BY HIS
CONVERSATIONSNOWSIFIEDOUT CONVEA
VERY CAREFULLY AND GET OUT OFHA.
RED PEN CIRCLE ALL THOSE
ON TO THIS
POINT? I MEAN, IS  MEADOWS WEOWT
WITNES YOU WOULD HTRIEDYWITH THA
UNTILEA
TOMPELLED T TESTIFY.
WS AND TATLAND
ALONGTHEOUR
WA BUT THAT'S A
BUREAUCRATICSROSECUTORIALPROACHN
AGGRESSIVE PNE
OR PERHAPS A M